je retrouve l'année dernière encore des
seringues dans ma des seringues
ensanglantées dans ma boîte aux lettres
avec des lettres anonymes me promettant
la mort
bonjour à tous C'est jeremstar et je
vais vous raconter mon histoire je suis
un survivant des réseaux sociaux durant
mon enfance j'avais pas forcément
confiance en moi j'étais pas malheureux
rejeté parce que j'étais différent à
l'école c'est vrai que bah durant mes
années collège surtout j'étais pas
forcément le garçon qui jouait au foot
je préférais jouer au Barbie ça plaisait
pas trop je veux voilà on se foutait un
peu de ma gueule parce que bah j'avais
une voix un peu aiguë parce que j'étais
féminée donc c'est vrai que je me
sentais pas vraiment rentrer dans le
moule je me rappelle que la cantine
j'avais pas vraiment de gens avec qui
manger je faisais pas partie des groupes
populaires de l'école et c'est vrai que
c'est assez violent quand on est jeune
et qu'on est en pleine construction
l'école c'est la première expérience
qu'on a en société et même c'est pas
ultra bien passé pour moi je me suis
toujours sentie c'est vrai pas hyper
bien intégré durant mon mon parcours
scolaire rapidement en grandissant après
pendant mon adolescence j'ai créé ce
personnage de Jeremstar qui m'a permis
de prendre confiance en moi et surtout
qui a été une belle revanche puisque
c'était le moment où j'ai décidé de
faire un gros doigt d'honneur à tous ces
gens qui me méprisaient me rabaissaient
à l'école et j'ai décidé voilà d'être
vachement dans la provogue vachement
dans l'acceptation à travers un coming
out un petit peu provocant à cet âge-là
et ça m'a vraiment aidé à travers ce
personnage vraiment à croire en moi j'ai
grandi forcément avec les émissions de
télé-réalité je comprenais pas trop
jeune pourquoi on enfermait des gens
comme des rats de laboratoire et puis
surtout je me disais mais pourquoi ces
gens là deviennent connus gagnent de
l'argent en ayant rien fait de leurs dix
doigts je vois pas pourquoi moi je
pourrais pas y arriver et c'est vrai
qu'à un moment donné j'ai été un petit
peu attiré par ce système là et j'ai eu
envie de faire de la téléréalité jusqu'à
bien que je comprenne que c'était pas
possible et qu'on comprenait pas donc
j'ai décidé à un moment donné de tout
simplement de la commenter et de de la
débriefer de la décrypter voilà c'est
vrai que je suis devenu vraiment le
spécialiste en matière de théorie sur
découvert du décor je balance énormément
sur les productions sur la drogue la
prostitution j'ai commencé à sortir
beaucoup de choses voilà qui
passionnaient les gens et qui était très
en demande c'est vrai que tout ce que je
sortais bah ça faisait beaucoup de bruit
j'ai été le premier à révéler
l'existence voilà d'un vrai réseau de
prostitution au sein de la télé-réalité
avec des candidats qui étaient recrutés
pour ensuite se vendre les pratiques
scatophiles dont on a encore beaucoup
reparlé ces derniers temps j'étais le
premier aussi à mettre le doigt dessus
j'ai vraiment balancé beaucoup de choses
sur la drogue qui avait sur les
tournages vraiment je n'avais pas de
rien et effectivement j'étais victime de
nombreuses pressions parce que je savais
beaucoup de choses d'ailleurs j'ai pas
tout dévoilé mais je savais beaucoup de
choses il faut savoir que à ce moment là
de ma carrière tout le monde m'envoyait
tout les policiers m'envoyaient les
dossiers les hôpitaux m'envoyer les
dossiers médicaux des gens des
célébrités tout le monde m'envoyait tout
et je me disais que le secret
professionnel et médical et voilà
n'existait vraiment pas c'est vrai que
pendant longtemps on a reproché d'avoir
été 100 fois ni loi d'avoir dépassé les
limites pourtant les gens ne savent pas
que j'ai gardé beaucoup de choses et que
je pense même que j'ai bien plus protégé
que je n'ai détruit des gens suite à
toutes ces révélations que je fais sur
le milieu de la téléréalité je commence
à comprendre que on veut me faire tomber
je suis victime de pression de menaces
il y a même un moment donné où je vais
devoir payer quelqu'un pour rester en
bas de chez moi pendant plusieurs
semaines parce que quand je révèle
toutes ces histoires prostitution ça
touche à des réseaux un petit peu
mafieux et donc ma sécurité est vraiment
en danger et quelques semaines après
effectivement le jeremstargate est lancé
alors encore aujourd'hui j'ai du mal à
comprendre mais enfin c'est très simple
en fait
on a orchestré en fait un petit peu ma
disgrâce parce que je savais beaucoup
trop de choses et parce que je révé
l'être autre chose je suis mêlé à des
histoires de mœurs terribles je me
retrouve accusé de choses que je n'ai
évidemment pas commise et alors là bah
ça va très vite parce que à partir de ce
moment là tous s'emballe médiatiquement
et surtout dernières années que j'ai
compris en ayant accès au dossier
judiciaire qui était derrière tout ça et
qui avait organisé tout ça en fait et ce
sont effectivement des personnes qui
sont très proches de ce milieu de
l'influence et de la téléréalité et que
ça dérangeait que je dévoile des choses
voilà sur la prostitution les pratiques
scatophiles on a orchestré ma disgrse
parce que ça dérangeait vraiment trop ça
a été un enfer à partir du moment où
vous êtes accusé de quelque chose sur
Internet aussi horrible soit-il parce
que moi m'accuser quand même de viol de
pédophilie enfin des mots
ignobles la pédophilie est quand même
l'un des pires fléaux de nos sociétés le
problème c'est que pour les gens qui
connaissent rien qui ne puissent pas la
suite de votre histoire vous êtes
condamné à vie et d'ailleurs c'est
encore le cas 5 ans après puisque
aujourd'hui tous les jours je suis
insulté de ces mots terribles et les
gens sont persuadés que c'est vrai et
c'est le syndrome il n'y a pas de fumée
sans feu les gens se disent que oui mais
enfin bon ça doit quand même être un peu
vrai non c'était faux mais vous avez
beau vous débattre trouver au monde
entier que c'est faux il y en a toujours
qui croiront et je pense même qu'il y en
a certains à qui ça fait plaisir d'y
croire même ils savent que c'est faux et
puis après ça n'a jamais ça ne s'est
jamais arrêté puisque une fois que ça
part sur Twitter le pire réseau social
au monde bah ça se répand partout
partout
un journaliste a été condamné d'ailleurs
en première instance cette année
dernière à de la prison ferme parce
qu'il m'avait harcelé et qu'il voulait
relancer mes polémiques et qu'il
m'accusait de tout et n'importe quoi sur
les réseaux donc en fait après c'est un
enfer sans fin c'est à dire que ça fait
5 ans que vraiment sur la sur Internet
bah je suis victime de ces rumeurs de
ces calomies et vraiment c'est terrible
parce que la rumeur tue vraiment je
lutte aujourd'hui je suis épuisé
émotionnellement de devoir expliquer que
c'est faux de devoir subir les
agressions que je subis numériquement
mais aussi dans la vraie vie parce que
les répercussions sont réelles quand on
vous accuse de faire aussi grave encore
une fois de l'un des pires fléaux de nos
sociétés la pédophilie bah c'est
terrible ça a été horrible franchement
cette période là je retrouve l'année
dernière encore des seringues dans ma
des seringues ensanglantées dans ma
boîte aux lettres avec des lettres
anonymes me promettant la mort parce
qu'encore une fois les gens ont une
haine extrême et sont persuadés que tout
ce qu'ils ont lu sur moi sont des choses
vraies il y a quelques jours encore j'ai
reçu une lettre anonyme que j'avais
dévoilé sur le plateau de Cyril Hanouna
une lettre anonyme terrible et c'est
vrai que ça fait peur parce que on se
dit ça ne s'arrête pas comme réseau
sociaux sont aussi des choses dans la
vraie vie heureusement que je suis fort
parce que j'en connais qui se sont
suicidés je suis persuadé que si je
m'étais donné la mort on aurait parlé de
mon histoire partout et que j'aurais été
réhabilité de façon posthume on aurait
eu de la de la tristesse on se serait
dit c'est parti trop loin c'est
dégueulasse qu'il a subi je ne me
suiciderai pas c'est tout mon combat et
c'est le titre de mon livre je suis un
survivant des réseaux sociaux et je dois
mener ce combat pour toutes les
personnes mortes c'est justement le
reflet d'un gros fléau de nos sociétés
le la lenteur judiciaire moi faut savoir
que vraiment c'est très très long voilà
encore une fois ça fait cinq ans que
j'ai mené des actions en justice qui
m'ont coûté en plus extrêmement cher
donc aujourd'hui
obtenir réparation ça coûte très cher
c'est très long et en fait on se dit
presque ça sert à rien parce que quand
on obtient ce petit document qui
condamne les personnes en fait 5 ans
après c'est un peu trop tard parce que
ça fait déjà 5 ans que le tribunal
populaire a rendu son verdict et que les
réseaux sociaux vous ont condamné donc
même si vous êtes innocenté ou même si
vous faites condamner vos cyber
agresseurs en justice il y a très peu de
gens qui le relieront mais pour autant
je pense qu'il faut vraiment s'accrocher
moi j'ai énormément évolué je pense que
dans ce milieu un petit peu puissacier
de télé-réalité de médias tout ça je
suis l'un des rares quand même à avoir
fait un mea culpa et à avoir reconnu la
merde que j'avais fait par le passé je
l'ai très souvent dit que oui j'avais
participé à des vagues de
cyber-harcèlement à un moindre niveau
quand même parce que j'ai jamais accusé
quelqu'un de pédophilier de viol ça
restait quand même assez léger des
interviews dans une baignoire et des
voilà des clashs entre candidats sur des
histoires de fesses bon on est quand
même loin
d'accusation criminelle mais c'est vrai
que j'ai contribué à ce système qui m'a
explosé en pleine tête et que je à la
parole dans ma baignoire à des gens qui
s'interrogent qui se clashèrent de
manière interposée que je donnais voilà
beaucoup de ragots et de potins sur mon
site internet et que quand j'aimais pas
quelqu'un dans une maison de téléréalité
parce que je considérais qu'il avait un
comportement de merde ou que il
harcelait un autre candidat c'est vrai
que j'appelais ma communauté voilà à
suivre mon point de vue et à ne pas
l'aimer pour ça vraiment j'ai présenté
plusieurs fois mes excuses à tous les
candidats de télé-réalité que j'avais
voilà un petit peu enfin beaucoup même
blessé et je suis tout à fait conscient
d'avoir eu des méthodes qui étaient pas
les bonnes d'avoir été un connard ça je
l'assume totalement j'ai aucun mal à le
reconnaître et je trouve ça même hyper
intéressant dans mon parcours de me
rendre compte de ce que j'ai été et de
ce que j'ai vécu aussi par la suite
parce que du coup aujourd'hui j'ai été
des deux côtés et le cyber-harcèlement
je le connais voilà en tant qu'initiator
par moment et en tant que victime c'est
pas pour autant que mon combat n'est pas
légitime et c'est pas pour autant que je
n'ai pas le droit à ce que justice soit
rendue et que je mérite de subir des
dénonciations
des rumeurs immonde je pense que voilà
la loi du talion n'existe pas c'est pas
parce que tu as fait des choses pas
terribles dans ta vie que tu n'as pas le
droit à ce que justice soit rendue et
encore une fois franchement entre des
histoires de fesses qui étaient mises en
avant par les candidats téléréalité
eux-mêmes c'est toujours d'ailleurs leur
business et des accusations de
pédophilie et de viol il y a quand même
un énorme fossé aujourd'hui je suis
encore en contact avec quelques
candidats de téléréalité plus beaucoup
c'est vrai que voilà je me suis pas mal
détaché de ce milieu là mais je fais
encore des interviews et des témoignages
parce que bah comme dans tout milieu
c'est pas parce que c'est des candidats
télé réalité qui font leur cracher
dessus ça reste des êtres humains qui
ont aussi des histoires et du vécu donc
je donne encore la parole à certains
même si je ne suis évidemment plus
spécialiste de la télé-réalité mais ce
qui est sur Oui c'est que je la connais
j'ai évolué elle m'a fait rêver elle m'a
aussi détruit la téléréalité elle m'a
broyé et puis tous les problèmes que
j'ai eu c'est aussi à cause de ce milieu
là